this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream curiositystream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of fascinating
documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals there's no
reality show nonsense here just
non-fiction entertainment enjoyed by
millions curiosity stream is available
on many platforms web app roku android
xbox one smart tvs ios chromecast amazon
fire amazon kindle and apple tv as well
as being available worldwide now look if
you like my channel and i imagine you
might since you are watching it head
over to curiositystream and check out
their docu-series history by the numbers
it's a very interesting series that
talks about some of the people we've
covered here on biographics as well as
some of the places that we talked about
on our sister channel geographics it's
great crossover stuff so you can go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics for unlimited access the
world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and right now you
guys can use the promo code biographics
and you'll get 25 off the cost of an
annual subscription which comes out to
only 14.99
a year which is crazy cheap so click the
link below or go to curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics and save 25
right now making it 14.99
for the whole year
and now back to today's video
she's one of the most important people
in american history the founding mother
who helped shape the newborn nation
almost as profoundly as some presidents
the wife of john adams abigail adams was
many things the first second lady the
second first lady she was also one of
only two women to ever be both the wife
of a president and the mother of a
president after her son john quincy
adams became the sixth
commander-in-chief but while we may
remember her today for a role in her
husband and son's lives there was so
much more to abigail adams than her
famous family a voracious learner at a
time when women were seen primarily as
baby making machines adams was one of
the best red people in the whole of
america she was also an incisive thinker
penning one of the nation's earliest
most influential opinions to equality
yet this intellect came with a hidden
dark side one that would lead her to
support massive curtailment of civil
liberties founding mother thinker one
time hate figure this is the life of
abigail adams american icon
[Music]
born on the 22nd of november 1744 or
november 11th in the old-style julian
calendar that was still in use at the
time abigail smith's family were
practically massachusetts royalty her
maternal grandfather or speaker of the
massachusetts assembly a title that it
hold for 40 years while her father
william smith was a highly esteemed
local minister luckier still by the
standards of the time he was also
incredibly progressive in this era the
idea of giving girls an education was
considered as ludicrous as the suit made
of custard they should be taught to do
chores and be marryable but stuff like
books theology and science well
that was for boys but not in william
smith's household against his wife's
wishes abigail's dad pressed her to read
not just poetry and the works of john
milton but also history philosophy and
more by the time she was 11 abigail was
extremely smart and extremely
comfortable in her smartness among
william's friends she was renowned for a
back chat one even declared
half-jokingly you will either be a very
good woman or else a very bad one still
while letting abigail get the education
she deserved was great and all we should
point out that william smith wasn't
completely progressive despite living
way up in massachusetts the family still
owned slaves four of them to be exact
phoebe tom cato and tower if you already
know a bit about abigail john adams and
their son john quincy this might come as
a bit of a shock today all three are
lauded for their opposition to slavery
yet abigail's position would always be
more complex than that of a husband and
son while she would support
massachusetts as 1783 abolition laws she
never regretted growing up around four
enslaved people in later life she would
even keep in touch with phoebe after she
was freed it said she even regarded her
as a friend but while william smith's
progressive credentials may have only
applied to equality among the sexes that
still had one incredibly important
impact in abigail's life aged 11 her
education was placed in the hands of
englishman richard cranch who quickly
developed a crush on her older sister
mary in 1759 cranch popped around to woo
mary with a friend in tow a balding 24
year old lawyer with a developing belly
and his own reputation as an
argumentative know-it-all that friend's
name was john adams and meeting him was
destined to change abigail's life well
eventually it would their first meeting
you see was not a success tiny abigail
barely five feet tall was only 15 and
john was hardly a looker in fact the day
ended with john adams privately
dismissing her as not fond not frank not
candid while abigail's mom declared john
vulgar and unmannered still the meetings
continued partly because the adams's and
the smiths were vaguely related and
partly because richard crench was
determined to get into mary's oldie
timey pants finally in 1761 something
clicked at a social gathering john
suddenly found himself looking at the
petite intelligent forthright girl with
new eyes eyes in which the pupils had
been replaced by cartoon love hearts
their subsequent engagement was long by
the stands at the time abigail's parents
insisted that she not wed until she was
18. at last on october 24 1764 the pair
tied the knot and immediately moved to
john's place in nearby braintree today
the town of quincy just eight months
later their daughter naby was born two
years after that abigail gave birth to
john quincy adams who'd grow up to be
the sixth president but for that to
happen america first needed to become
independent and both abigail and john
were going to have front row seats to
the coming war
[Music]
when people talk of the founding fathers
there's a tendency to paint them as
being saints dudes in fancy coats
thinking deeply and conducting
themselves with utmost decorum but for
those actually around them the founding
fathers weren't abstract icons they were
real people real people who could
sometimes be really annoying for abigail
adams that annoyance came from jon
spending barely any time at home instead
vanishing for days on into boston or
even outside massachusetts for work the
result was abigail spending vast periods
of time alone time in which she was
expected to raise their children oversee
the farm sought out the finances and
generally deal with everything it was a
grim life for a bright young woman one
made worse by jon repeatedly forgetting
to write her letters while away to be
fair tim though john adams had other
things on his mind things like the
colonies deteriorating relationship with
the british one of the reasons john was
having to move about so much was because
the stamp act attacks on every piece of
paper used had just been levied causing
his legal work to dry up while it would
be repealed in 1766 subsequent british
attempts to attack the colonists were
driving things to boiling point
everybody could feel there was a
disaster looming and on march the 5th
1770 it finally arrived the boston
massacre was the killing of five unarmed
men by british soldiers after they were
cornered by a yelling mob by this time
adams has had been living in boston
itself for two years two years in which
abigail was able to abate her loneliness
somewhat and jon was able to get into
local politics the massacre though took
him to the big time but not in the way
they might think when the trial of the
soldiers came it was john who defended
them arguing they'd been provoked by the
mob he won the case the brits were
acquitted naturally bostonians were
absolutely furious the entire family
became a flame of discontent to which a
whole bunch of angry moths were being
drawn but was abigail upset
no not one bit despite her growing
anti-british sentiment abigail fully
supported her husband's decision to take
the case not just for the publicity
boost it gave his career but for the
principles at stake the last bit is
important because abigail adams wasn't
merely a dutiful wife standing by her
man while she'd always defend her
husband vociferously she was also more
than happy to slap him down when she
thought he was wrong as
we'll soon see for now though the case
made jon's name starting him down a
twisting path that would in 1774 lead to
him being invited to the first
continental congress sadly for abigail
that would mean even more time stuck at
home alone the next few months were
basically like watching a movie about
all the epic stuff you remember from
your american history class but one
focused entirely on a character forcibly
kept away from all the epicness as the
congress formed and dissolved then
reformed again in the wake of the
battles of lexington and concord abigail
adams found herself trapped in the role
of spectator while she used this time to
develop her political thinking helped by
correspondence with early feminists like
mercy otis warren it was mostly a
baronere in her life in one letter she
called being stuck on the sidelines my
patriotic sacrifice so it was
practically a relief when the war hit
their part of massachusetts the outbreak
of fighting upended the lives of
everyone in braintree not least abigail
adams as refugees streamed in she and
her son john quincy were able to stand
on the lawl and watch the distant battle
of bunker hill with war came more
exciting work in secret letters she
informed john of british troop movements
at the massachusetts colony general
court she took up a post rooting out
female spies and women with pro-british
sympathies yet the challenge to
abigail's life in those years wouldn't
be things becoming more exciting but
that she'd soon find herself more alone
than ever
the years of the second continental
congress were hard ones for abigail
adams while jon was off making speeches
and rocking a powdered wig she was
dealing with not just loneliness and the
stress of running a farming household
but also a heap of additional disasters
there was the smallpox outbreak of 1776
which got so bad that abigail was forced
to get the children inoculated a
terrifying decision in an era when
inoculation carried a small but
significant risk of death
and there was the ever-present fear of
an armed attack in 1777 abigail lost an
unborn child while hiding from a british
army rumored to be bearing down on
boston but we don't want to give the
impression that she was just some
passive actor buffeted by the winds of
history even in the depths of her
despair abigail adams was working to
shape her nation's future most
remarkably this came in the form of her
letters to john demanding the soon-to-be
independent congress make equality one
of its central pillars abigail c neither
guys who wrote the sentence we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal were indeed just
focusing on the equality of men folk
hence her remember the ladies letter of
march 1776 in which she both asked john
to codify female rights and threatened
him if he didn't saying if particular
attention is not paid to the ladies we
are determined to foment a rebellion and
will not hold ourselves bound by any
laws in which we have no voice or
representation nor was she just
interested in helping white women as far
back as 1774 abigail had written to john
on the issue of slavery telling him i
wish my sincerely that there was not a
slave in the province it always seemed
to me to fight ourselves for what we are
robbing the negroes of who have as good
a right to freedom as we have for the
era she lived in this was radical stuff
suggesting an america where not just
property only white guys but also women
and maybe even non-whites could have a
stake sadly it was too radical even jon
brushed her requests off when the
declaration of independence was signed
it said nothing about women being equal
still the severing of ties with britain
did at least mean a load of shiny new
posts and duties and for john adams that
meant once again vanishing off and
leaving his wife utterly alone between
1778 and 1783 john spent most of his
time in europe on various diplomatic
missions taking their sons john quincy
and charles with him that meant yet more
empty months in which abigail was forced
to sit in the ant chamber of history
missing out on the action while her
husband
repeatedly forgot to write if you grew
up with the sanitized version of their
story you might remember hearing how
devoted to one another the atoms as were
and how much john admired abigail's
intellect while that's true it also
misses out how utterly crappy their
relationship sometimes was in this era
of loneliness abigail told people she
felt as if she were widowed she even
tried to find solace in an unconsummated
affair with a notorious ladies man
finally in 1784 she seems to have had
enough of just waiting around taking her
daughter naby with her abigail boarded a
boat for europe leaving war shattered
america behind the move likely saved a
marriage for the next four years the
adams has lived together in london now
at peace with the us finally able to
enjoy one another's company as one of
the couple's modern biographers joseph j
ellis writes of this time they learn to
love each other at an even deeper level
than before and locked that love in
place and nothing they experienced for
the rest of their lives ever threatened
their mutual trust by the time they
returned to the now independent united
states in 1788 the era of abigail being
just an observer of history
was over from now on she and her husband
would work together to shape events for
millions
the first election in american history
was probably the most predictable
running effectively unopposed george
washington became president after a
lengthy ballot process what was exciting
though was the race for vice presidents
in this era parties didn't really yet
exist with the primary divisions being
between the federalists who john adams
supported and the anti-federalists that
meant no such thing as tickets with
people voting for a vp chosen by the
presidential nominee instead the vice
presidency was dependent on the votes of
electors and in the end those electors
gave john adams a plurality the
ascension of john to the number two spot
in the government made abigail adams the
first second lady in u.s history
although the term wasn't yet used at the
time in fact a lot of things that we
associate with modern elected government
simply didn't exist the capital for one
thing was still new york a city abigail
admired and enjoyed living in
unfortunately for her it would switch to
philadelphia after just one year at a
city she hated with miserable weather
that triggered her rheumatism as a
result the second lady would spend most
of her time back on their farm in
braintree itself soon to be renamed
quincy another way governance differed
was that the vice president's family
didn't get any official help at all
while washington was given a modest home
to live in and had the resources to
throw lavish parties the addamses were
forced to find themselves a house and
pay for everything since this coincided
with abigail and john having financial
difficulties it meant living a spartan
existence on the fringes of society
continually ignored in favor of richer
members of the cabinet speaking of which
that's one thing that was similar to
today's era the complete and utter
uselessness of the vp job while it might
have separated them abigail had been
proud of her husband's vital work in the
continental congress now they were both
simply frustrated with his meaningless
position with john's inability to even
speak during senate debates the only
good thing about being veep was how it
made him the natural choice to become
the next president we say natural
because again these were early days and
the concept of american democracy was
still pretty fragile when george
washington announced he would retire
after two terms abigail and john were
basically all like great it's our turn
next and they were genuinely shocked
when they had to face a competitive
election back in 1793 john's old frenemy
thomas jefferson had quit as secretary
of state over a rift between the
federalists and the anti-federalists now
jefferson joined forces with james
madison to found the democratic
republican party it's these dudes john
would have to fight in america's first
competitive election for her part
abigail was so furious that jefferson
was standing against her husband that
she cut off a long-term correspondence
with him they wouldn't write to one
another again for over a decade over
november and december 1796 the states
held their elections with 70 electoral
college votes needed to win jefferson
nabbed 68 while john adams cinched it
with 71. unfortunately the weird system
in place at the time meant jefferson
would now become vice president and in
the wake of a toxic election that would
clearly spell trouble abigail sought as
much despite revelling in her husband's
victory she seemed to instinctively know
that the coming four years would turn
her into a lightning rod for discontent
i expect to be vilified and abused she
wrote to a friend predicting she would
figuratively be fastened up hand and
foot and tongue to be shot at as our
quincy lads do at the poor geese and
turkeys it was a bleak assessment of the
state of american politics a dark vision
of what was to come
unfortunately
is also right
abigail adams became america's second
first lady on march the 4th 1797 at the
age of 52. it was the highest profile
role that should hold in her lifetime
and that was a problem because if
there's one thing we know about abigail
adams it's that she was more than happy
to speak her mind and wars on her mind
in 1797 was the way the press and the
democratic republicans were out for a
husband after a bruising election john
adams assumed office with his enemies
determined to make him fail the press
was merciless in its treatment of him
when abigail adams responded with
withering condescension towards
jefferson's followers the press attacked
her as well at times this edged into
dark territory because she found
philadelphia so unpleasant abigail was
still spending a lot of time in
massachusetts this meant writing to john
to keep up to date but people started
intercepting their letters and
publishing their contents a sort of
low-tech version of hacking someone's
emails perhaps unsurprisingly abigail
was rather pissed she began writing her
own partisan attacks having federalist
newspapers publish anonymous screeds
kneecapping her opponents with her acid
tongue no doubt it was incredibly
cathartic yet it also did very little to
help the knives were out for the second
president and in some quarters
everything the couple did was merely
another good excuse to drive the blade
even deeper there was the controversy
over john quincy who abigail had raised
to be as bookish as bright and as
argumentative as she was traits her
husband assumed would serve the boy well
as ambassador to prussia unfortunately
jqa's posting abroad triggered cries of
nepotism among jefferson supporters then
there were the controversies like the
xyz affair now we're not going to go
into too much depth on this because
we'll probably cover it in a future john
adams video but the crib sheet version
is that america sent some diplomats to
france to try and sort out a brewing
spat only for those diplomats to be
shaken down for a bribe by three men
working for the delightfully corrupt
foreign minister talarand the scandal
was so great that many pushed president
adams to declare war on france when he
stopped short of formally announcing a
conflict anti-federalist partisans
declared abigail was influencing his
judgment to be honest in many ways she
was today historians the gabigal adams
had a big hand in some of her husband's
picks for important roles and helped
nudge him on policy it's not for nothing
that the opposition's nickname of mrs
president stuck she really was a key
player but not in the xyz affair in this
instance abigail stood against osborne
demanding john declare war on paris when
it came to the most notorious aspect of
his presidency of all though abigail
would be firmly on john's side by 1798
the country was so divided and the
undeclared quasi war with france so
damaging that the first couple were
living in fear john of mass civil
disobedience abigail of violence
committed against their family hence the
alien earned seditions act an act
abigail championed but one that had gone
down in infamy a vicious assault on
civil liberties the act was
anti-immigrant pro-executive power and
extremely anti-free speech the alien's
part gave the president the power to
deport any foreigner he personally
didn't like a serious cudgel in a nation
of immigrants but the sedition's part
was even worse intended to stop partisan
attacks the act basically banned free
speech and freedom of the press
mandating arrest for anyone who insulted
the president and adams used these
powers leading democratic republican
newspapers were shut down and people
were put on trial including a
congressman who merely accused the
president of being pompous from
abigail's perspective the act was
exactly what the nation needed a firm
way for her husband to punish those who
wronged him but the crackdown would have
consequences neither of them could have
foreseen now newly energized the
democratic republicans were determined
to make sure john adams broke another
historical record the first one-term
president in history
november 1800 saw the adams at last
leave hated philadelphia behind and
relocate to the new capital of
washington dc unfortunately the white
house wasn't finished yet building work
was ongoing and there are cute anecdotes
of abigail hanging the families washing
in the incomplete east room but while it
might have been better than philly
abigail and john's time in the federal
capital would be overshadowed by misery
the first dark cloud settled over the
white house on the 30th of november that
day abigail's son charles died of
alcoholism aged only 30. as you might
imagine this was heartbreaking not just
because they'd lost a son but because
they'd lost him in such a senseless
self-destructive way yet there was
already another dark cloud already
looming up to join the first one which
would soon soak the first lady in a bit
of rain held from october 31 to december
the 3rd the 1800 election was basically
a re-run of 1796 pitting john adams and
the federalists against jefferson's
democratic republicans it even ended
with a similar score with the winning
side just edging to victory with 73
electoral votes the difference is this
time those all-important extra votes
went to thomas jefferson from a
historical perspective the election
marked the beginning of the greatest
winning streak in u.s history the
democratic republicans would now win
every presidential election until they
imploded after 1824 a seven victory run
unmatched by any party since from
abigail adams's perspective though it
marked nothing more than the end of her
husband's career the couple left the
white house in march 1801 and returned
to quincy massachusetts under a cloud of
depression but while it sucked to lose
abigail was clear-eyed about what it
meant a few regrets she wrote to her son
at my age and with my bodily infirmities
i shall be happier at quincy in all
likelihood she was right back in
massachusetts abigail found herself
freed from the partisan attacks from the
relentless politicking and ill feelings
she found time to write striking up a
number of correspondences remarkably
this included thomas jefferson after his
daughter died in 1804 abigail wrote to
the president to offer her condolences
re-establishing contact between the two
of them although she'd always maintain
that his vision for america was the
incorrect one she would come around to
seeing the man once again as a friend of
course the big thing happening around
this time was her son's rise just as
john adams's star was fading john
quincy's was beginning to burn with
nuclear fire after switching allegiance
to the democratic republican party jqa
became ambassador to russia before
settling in britain and marrying an
english woman throughout abigail wrote
to him as she had once to john offering
advice pressing her political
convictions helping guide and shape his
path by 1818 the boy was back living in
the u.s and in the exalted position of
secretary of state for abigail this
meant a chance to bask in the glow of
her son's success to be proud of the
up-and-coming politician that she'd
helped create yet she'd never get to see
him become president on october 28 1818
abigail adams passed away at home from
typhoid fever she was 73. one of the
last acts had been to write a will
defiantly bucking the laws at the time
that said all of her money and property
belonged to the man she was married to
instead she left nearly everything to
her female relatives if congress
wouldn't dane to remember the ladies
then
by god abigail would today abigail adams
remains a central figure in the early
story of america a woman so important
that she's sometimes referred to as a
founding mother in a way that's a little
surprising as vital as she was to jon
and john quincy's political development
her most passionately held beliefs
failed to make their mark congress
forgot the ladies and slavery wouldn't
be abolished until decades after she
died but perhaps what's important is
that she pushed these ideas regardless
that she fought to make the new nation
the best version of itself that it could
possibly be she might not have succeeded
but by trying she set a powerful example
one that would inspire not just future
americans but people all over the world
[Music]
you